es-tu favorable au divorce légalement je
trouve ça bien que ce soit le divorce
autorisé bien sûr mais je trouve ça pas
bien quel genre divorce soit à
l'avortement
c'est dommage
c'est dommage qui est des circonstances
où les femmes sont obligées d'avorter
mais il faut bien évidemment le
continuer à faire en sorte que les les
lois qu'ils autorisent soit respectée
partout qu'il rende l'avortement libre
gratuit qui le décrit minya lisent que
ces lois soient maintenus ou créés à
l'euthanasie
je ferai que chacun puisse faire son
testament et dire non mais c'est
vachement compliqué ça à partir de quand
est-ce qu'on peut décider qu'un mec
souffre trop et que s'il est inconscient
j'ai bon la question des routes et
priori je m'en fous à la peine de mort
bah donc même pour les assassins
d'enfants
ça c'est la question vicieuse et obsède
par excellence même pour les assassins
d'enfants
c'est la question piège mais quoi qu'il
arrive une société civilisée peut pas
trancher la tête un individu
quoi qu'il ait fait et tu favorable au
droit de vote pour les immigrés ouais
plutôt est ce que tu crois en dieu
non mais je fais gaffe quand même
et je me conduis je me comme disait
brassens je me conduis qui a plus mal
que si j'avais la foi si tu avais un
dernier message des brouillards suivait
un dernier message à donner à ta petite
fille serait quoi je verrai ça y est tu
peux toucher avec à la bêche et pour
être sûr de ne rien rater de 1h10 tube
abonnez vous il mettait un peu de bleu